We will now formulate the clustering
problem that we define informally in
the previous section as
a rigorous computational problem.
And I think a good clustering should
satisfy the Good Clustering Principle,
which says that elements
within the same cluster
should be closer to each other than
elements in different clusters.
Or, in other words, there should
be a parameter "delta" such that
distance between elements in
the same cluster is less than delta,
and distance between elements in
different clusters is larger than delta.
For example, is this clustering
satisfying the Good Clustering Principle?
Of course not because there are
elements in the same cluster that
are further away from each other than from
elements in different clusters.
However, this problem is easy to
fix because here's a clustering
satisfying the Good Clustering Principle.
And therefore, we come up
the following Clustering Problem:
Find a partition of expression
vectors into clusters
that satisfies
the Good Clustering Principle.
But how about the example below this line?
Can we construct clustering satisfying
the Good Clustering Principle?
It turns out that it doesn't matter
how much we try: there is no
partition satisfying the Good
Clustering Principle for this dataset,
which means that the problem that we just
formulated, while it is a well defined
computational problem, is essentially
useless for most practical dataset
because most of them do not
have a partition satisfying
the Good Clustering Principle.
Thus, we have to figure out how to
construct a new objective function for
clustering that will generate
a solution for any dataset.
Here is a small dataset of four points
and four different ways to cluster.
Which of them is the best cluster?
Our goal now is to come up with the notion
of the objective function for clustering.
And to do this, I will take
liberty to reformulate the goal of
clustering into the equivalent goal
of finding centers of clusters.
For example, below, you can see a dataset
consisting of eight blue points and
three points representing Centers
of clusters for this dataset.
Our goal is to come up with the notion
of distance between Data and Centers,
and then after we come up with the notion
we want to find Centers that
minimize this distance.
But what is the distance
from Data to Centers?
To define the notion of distance
from Data to Centers, we will first
define the notion of distance from
a single DataPoint to Centers.
And in this case,
it's natural to define this distance
as the distance from a DataPoint
to it's closest Center.
For example,
the distance from this blue point will
be the distance to its closest center,
and we can construct
distances to all four
DataPoints in this way.
Now, we only defined the distance
from a single DataPoint to Centers.
Our goal now is to define the distance
from all DataPoints to Centers.
What will this natural
notion of such distance?
And I think maximum distance among
the distances we just computed would
be the natural notion of the
distance between Data and Centers.
That's how we define the MaxDistance
objective function for clustering.
After we define the notion of MaxDistance,
we are ready to formulate
the k-Center Clustering Problem:
Given a set of points Data,
find k Centers minimizing maximum
distance between Data and Centers.
You see at the bottom of the slide
an example with eight blue points and
three Centers.
These three Centers are very poorly chosen
as a solution of the k-Center
Clustering Problem.
These Centers would be a better solution.
But is it the optimal solution of
the k-Center Clustering Problem?
Actually no, because there is a different
partition of points in the clusters
that gives an even better solution of
the k-Center Clustering Problem.
Anyway, it appears that the k-Center
Clustering Problem appears to be a rather
simple problem, but it turns out
that it's actually NP-Complete.
Therefore, we have to develop
an approximation algorithm for solving it,
and our next task is to create a
k-Center Clustering Heuristic
that is called the FarthestFirstTraversal.
The FarthestFirstTraversal starts from
choosing an arbitrary point as
the first Center of the cluster.
At the next step, which point
would you choose as the next Center?
The reasonable approach is to choose
the point that is the farthest apart
from the existing cluster,
which will be this point.
Afterwards, we find that the distances
from the already constructed clusters
to all DataPoints,
and to choose the next cluster,
we simply select the distance
that is largest among the constructed
distances and this is our third cluster.
If we only need to construct three clusters,
we are done, and this is the clustering:
a partitioning of eight points into
three clusters that
the FarthestFirstTraversal produces.
Now, after we design
the FarthestFirstTraversal algorithm,
lets ask the question: What is wrong
with this algorithm in practice?
Well, FarthestFirstTraversal selects
Centers that minimize the maximum distance.
But biologists are often interested in
typical, rather than maximum, distances
because maximum distances often
represent experimental errors or outliers.
For example,
in this case of a simple clustering
problem that is presented below,
let's see how the human eye and
FarthestFirstTraversal would solve
the problem.
The human eye will immediately see
three clusters and will ignore outliers.
FarthestFirstTraversal, on
the other hand, will always
construct three clusters and miss
the correct clustering of the points.
We therefore need to develop
a different approach to clustering
that works well with outliers.
To come up with this new
clustering approach,
we first need to modify
objective function for clustering.
Our MaxDistance Objective Function
designed for
the k-Center Clustering Problem
has its limitations.
Please note that only one of the distances
shown below contributes to MaxDistance.
Instead, we will use a new
Objective Function
called the squared error distortion.
The squared error distortion
is the sum of squares
of all distances, divided by the
number of points in the dataset.
So, for the maximum distance,
a single DataPoint contributes
to the objective function,
while for the distortion, all DataPoints
contribute to the objective function.
And as soon as we define
the squared error distortion,
we define the k-Means Clustering Problem.
And the only difference between the
k-Center Clustering Problem and
the k-Means Clustering Problem
is that the k-Means clustering problem is
that the k-Means Clustering Problem tries
to optimize distortion,
rather than maximum distance.
In this case, the Centers chosen shown
in this slide are not good Centers,
and after we apply the k-Centers
Clustering Problem,
they will move to different points.
After we apply the k-Means
Clustering Problem,
they also will move to different points,
and please note that they
have moved to different
positions than in the k-Center
Clustering Problem.
Now, it may appear that k-Means
Clustering Problem is simple, but
it turns out to be NP-Hard even for
partitioning the set of DataPoints
into just two clusters.
The only case when
there are polynomial algorithms for
the k-Means Clustering Problem is
the case when k is equal to one.
You may think that there is no point
in clustering DataPoints into one cluster,
because this clustering is given.
Indeed, we are not trying to
cluster the dataset into one cluster:
we are trying to find the best
center of this cluster and
you will see in the next section that
it will be actually very helpful.
However, how do we find
a center of a cluster?
So,
how do we develop an algorithm for k-Means
Clustering when k is equal to 1?
Well, in this case, there is
the Center of Gravity Theorem, which
says that the center of gravity of
points Data is the only point,
remember, only is important here,
the only point solving
the 1-Means Clustering Problem.
To remind you,
the center of gravity of points Data,
if we represent every point as a vector,
is simply the sum of these vectors divided
by the number of vectors in the dataset,
or, in other words, the i-th coordinate
of the center of gravity is simple
the average of the i-th coordinate
of all points in the dataset.
And now, after we introduce
the notion of k-means clustering,
we are ready to describe
the Lloyd algorithm,
the most popular
approximation algorithm for
solving the k-Means Clustering Problem.